[Music]
what do you guys think of a restaurant
that forces you to wear this what both
of the swim noodles yeah swim noodles on
hand and it's a swim noodle on it and
it's like a helicopter shape it's not
even long enough it's not long enough
yeah it's not six feet that looks like
two and a half you know is much for the
quarantine thing walk around like that
like on this really actually pictures of
other people with that like they wear
that so people can like stay away from
them honestly I miss restaurants so much
Sam I'd be down to do it really yeah it
looks like a court jester yeah I just
feel like okay say like someone's
walking with like drinks and stuff and
then you turn your head you knock over
everything on your own table just great
doesn't that look like Europe or
something yeah it's in Germany so this
this restaurant is cafe in Germany think
of forgot the name [ __ ] I mean yes I'm
talking they got to be really careful
with their like cross shaped symbols
though yeah so the German Cafe cafe and
Condit or a Roth and Schwerin Germany I
went to a German doughnut spot and it
was really really good really well it
did what was like in Germany when you
were out there like what were like some
of the things that they were doing they
weren't doing [ __ ] dude really we're
just we took the last train out before
they closed the border so at the time
Austria shut down completely like
universities all that public gatherings
everything closed so like that was the
day before and then we went to Germany
we were in Munich we're hanging out
nothing we were eating at restaurants
people were gathering drinking beer it
was it was awesome
yeah and then we were like maybe we
should go back and and thankfully we did
cuz we were gonna do like two more days
and they closed the border
panicking there no one was there sense
of panic there cuz I felt like there was
a sense of panic here oh yeah oh no no I
was right every word bump into each
other like that day was like I could
feel and see the way people move with
shopping carts just like the energy of
the whole city and just watching the
videos and like everything when I was in
Europe
I thought America and Australia was
freaking out and I was kind of laughing
at you guys you're an American you're
hurt you're germ at the time I was
Austrian and yeah dude people were chill
like they were shopping like usual
people are out it's just I think they
know how to assemble and follow the
rules out there a little bit better and
they were I was fine I'll skating and
then the cop came up and and told me to
[ __ ] go home and knows it I was a
stupid American that was breaking the
rule playing outside well we were told
that we can go out and like bike jog
like like run or walk right so I thought
might as well just go skating and and
that was that wasn't allowed like that
you're in Germany and you're like what
could I do in Germany
I'll go ski that's my picture Joe duty
really he was having fun I did you have
to rent a skateboard it was my friends
okay and it was her idea
I mean there's nothing to do like
everything's closed museums everything
so we're like let's enjoy the city but
on skateboard you I thought was crazy in
Germany is that everywhere everything
shuts down on Sundays too like
everything shuts down like Jack away
everywhere yeah but yeah but everywhere
yeah no you can't go to a drugstore you
can't go to a grocery store you can't go
like you can't go anywhere yes we were
doing this Europe tour where we were
only in each country for two days yeah
and so we had got there on a Saturday
and the next day I like really needed
some stuff at the drugstore and
everything was shut down all these
super-religious out there yeah I don't
know if it was because of that our way
it was because of but they were just
like the culture people chill yeah no
one works on Sundays yeah yeah they
don't work as much Europeans are really
chill like I mean I'm so lazy right
yeah maybe yeah baths of all the place
has ever been like it just seems like
there are a lot more like content with
just sitting on a cafe and spending like
half their day yeah you know what you
guys that here I know that sounds nice
though hey that's not nice I think
that's the way you're supposed to be
like there's too much stress here like
if you think it's a la thing I think
it's an American thing it's Gary's fault
[ __ ] Gary Vee trying to make
everybody a hustler and I get work all
hard and [ __ ] that's what I like about
America is that you can work as hard as
you want and you can you can there's no
ceiling to where you can get to
everyone's working out how are you
supposed to drink coffee with people
exactly with finding a little house with
a helicopter yeah like you call your
friends everyone a hustler like can we
just grab an espresso and you can well
yeah why don't like is that you're
guilted into having to work hard like
for people that don't want to like pour
all that energy into it they're like
well I guess I have to to keep up cuz
yeah what are you doing today I'm just
working on my hustle yeah you know I
mean then let's grab coffee it doesn't
to me in like with the context of
America in mind I don't feel like it's
meant to go chill and relax and have a
business ya know it's like okay coffee
alright I mean remind laptop and my
other stuff in my notes for some reason
and like it romantically it means I
don't wanna [ __ ] you yet just get
together
coffee meets bagel yeah who's that it's
a it's a dating app ugly people huh yeah
it was more like let's get to know each
other for possibly a relationship is not
not tinder style yeah yeah I did notice
though like girls would rather meet up
for it's way easier to be able to go
over coffee then then find out more
about you then what I'm gonna do yeah
it's so like it's too much of a
commitment man they couldn't a coffee is
like let's chill and if after we're done
let's go home you know isn't like a date
could be like all night well compared to
like coffees like an hour done I
finished my coffee else yeah exactly
me I'm like a date is stressful you got
to get ready and all that I was talking
about this with my friend out in the
Czech Republic like he's from OC and
he's moved out there a couple years now
and he was like dating is so much easier
because of proximity so he was talking
about how
in LA like it's a whole event right like
it takes 40 plus minutes to get ya there
to meet up you want to look good you
want to do all this stuff it's a whole
[ __ ] event so he says that the
commitment is so much more so you have
to go through like so much just to meet
this one person and for Europe he's like
it's literally like let's go walk out
the park real quick on tinder real quick
it's like boom yeah I'll see you in like
30 minutes the park and you're like yeah
we could go to another date or like Matt
takes the pressure off yeah he goes like
there's a coffee shop right down the
street that locally everyone knows and
don't like yeah I'll see you there so
there's not that much of a pressure to
like perform or anything and like if it
doesn't work out it doesn't work out and
then you move on to the next plus I feel
old all that pressure people aren't
showing the real self yeah yeah much
less likely that you're gonna see
someone in their authentic form when
they're like presenting and putting on a
show someone eyes you gotta show off
yeah person like it's like a whole that
did a good job interview yeah I like to
picture Joe doe getting ready and
putting his ponytail like this is the
perfect pony this is just me he got his
nice tie out today so you could put on a
ponytail but I teased it a little bit
like kind of bouffant going I'm gonna do
it top knees depending on how long this
quarantine stay-at-home thing is gonna
last Joe would you ever date and try to
like figure like some sort of like
romantic life through zoom and like
online type stuff oh he's like everyone
seems to be doing that like a Berber
were relegated to that I've done long
distance you know but I I still have to
see the person to take it to the next
level I think because there's so many
things that are more important than just
looks like smell that you can't that's
the first date look best
this is me doing my onion look this is
my radish Joe 90s comedy like one of
those fishes that the angler Elmo
crossing no if there's one of those
animal crossing we have them in real
life too you know what's cool though is
that like people are now it's interest
for us to kind of stay home you just
gotta get to know somebody true it's not
any means necessary
I'm starting to get to know Gio
sometimes I call Steve on zoom and like
zoomed a with him yeah it actually is
tiring going all the way downstairs and
across and today's everything real so I
don't zoom him but I do call him we call
each other to like hey you need it yeah
you're like can you get my water bottle
can you also hear the echo going down
the stairs while the phone no not until
he comes closer to the stairs but if
he's all the way back in his office it's
like he's in a different place
he's like in a different building
because I want to go on a zoom date but
I'm married and I'm like [ __ ] you can't
do it but yeah just their home different
room one person's downstairs one
person's upstairs I like get dressed up
video chatting is pretty fun though it
is fun yeah
it's little it's harder though I would
say there's a little overlap yeah I like
I feel like a lot of communication is
nonverbal gestures yeah so not being
able to everyone being stiff like
looking at the same place it's like
you're not getting the same just height
type of communication and bonding
experience that you get can't touch each
other I've noticed that over FaceTime
and stuff like you're actually gonna
talk a lot more because they're in the
place that they're comfortable your and
yours and you actually just talking for
a long time it's more casual than a lot
of people you don't have to like look a
certain way or try to like be perfect
cuz you're right there and nervous and
you have that barrier between the fun
that you can like break that down first
and then when you do go see them it's a
wave oh I know what you're talking about
yeah yeah
you get comfortable with them so by the
time you see them you just feel like
yeah it was never like I've never faced
I'm a girl we're going on a FaceTime
date because I have another in the
courtroom but like previously like if I
start talking to a girl then we talked
through FaceTime and then when we see
each other I think we know each other
it's like I already seen your [ __ ] I
think if it was a stranger I'd be more
like like that but if it was like my
group of friends I feel more pressure to
keep the conversation going and do not
have like a die and like it feels weird
because we're not allowed to like break
off and have side conversations you know
how like if you're in a gathering if
you're like an insolence living room you
start talking and then you like kind of
break off and do side conversations but
you can't really do that in a zoom call
yes like this yep you start another zoom
call with them yeah yeah I feel like
with them you talk [ __ ] about someone
that they they're like why are you
texting me separately we're right in
here need to be really good at
conversation of that though right
because you have to like that's all you
got compared to if you're going on a
date and let's say you're getting coffee
you could take like moments in between
to like drink your coffee and you go
back blew this coffee so good
yeah and you're observing you could fold
the napkin a little bit and then she
goes fine that's you bull just say
fiddling with [ __ ] like you know see
that's what I'm saying how do you judge
someone properly and all their stupid
annoying habits if it's just you and
them on FaceTime you've got to see what
annoying [ __ ] they do a frown no boo
maybe they're not annoying [ __ ] because
they're nervous right so you get through
that with FaceTime you actually talk no
I need to judge you don't like the
nervous well that's what I'm saying like
maybe maybe you might be nervous
[Music]
[Music]